معنا من مستشفى ناصر في خانيونس مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر اذا اسماعيل
تمكنت من الوصول الى مستشفى ناصر التي
ايضا يتعرض محيطها لقصف مستمر ما الوضع
لديك اسماعيل هل تسمعني نعم اسمعك ما
الوضع لديك اسماعيل في مستشفى
ناصر يعني في مستشفى ناصر حاليا يتم نقل
الاصابات من منطقه الصناعه حيث يتواجد
النازحون هناك سقط عدد قف مدفعيه واصابت
عدد من النازحين يتم نقلهم من قبل طواقم
الاسعاف التابع لوزاره الصحه باتجاه
مستشفى ناصر هناك ايضا تم نقل عدد من
الشهداء من اكثر من منطقه نحاول الوصول
الى اعداد هؤلاء الشهداء الذين وصلوا الى
مستشفى ناصر في ظل غارات ليليه وصباحيه من
قبل طيارات الاحتلال على اهداف عديده في
مفه خان يونس احزمه ناريه قصف عنيف مدفعي
وكذلك من طائرا الاحتلال باتجاه اهداف
عديده وكنا نتحدث بان هناك عدد من الشهداء
ايضا ما زالوا في جامعه الاقصى يصعب وصول
سياره الاسعاف الى تلك المنطقه وطق
الاسعاف لديها اولويات حاليا في نقل
الاصابات
اي اوهي تسنى للطواقم الطبيه تعامل مع هذه
الاصابات وانقاذ ما يمكن انقاض هذ
الاصابات الكبير جراء غارات الاحتلال على
اكثر من من هدف ايض قارات الاحتلال خلال
الاحزمه الناريه الليليه قامت بقصف احد
طوابق مستشفى مستشفى الخير الواقع بالقرب
من مستشفى ناصر الى الغرب من مستشفى ناصر
وكان ايضا هذا المستشفى يستقبل اصابات
وكذلك مرضى ويستقبل نازحين في اروقه هذا
المستشفى ومحيط هذا المستشفى لكن مع وصول
اليه الاحتلال الى هذا المستشفى نزح كافه
المواطنون والجرحى من هذا المستشفى في ظل
صعبه وعدم توفر وسائل نقل ومواصلات لهؤلاء
المواطنين والنازحين وهم يحملون امتعتهم
على ظهورهم احيانا هناك من يتوفر له وسيله
المواصلات وينقل هذه الامتعه باتجاه مناطق
امنه غرب محافظه خلس وحتى باتجاه مدينه
رفح حدث بان الان انا وصلت الى المشرحه
والمغسله لمشفى ناصر امامي اكثر من 20
شهيد
يعني مسجون في هذه اللحظات في ساحه
المشرحه هؤلاء ارتقوا بعضهم في
غارات الاحتلال التي نفذت الليله اليه
وفجر هذا اليوم على اهداف عديده وحاله
صعبه جدا في ظل هذا العدد الكبير من
الشهداء وهناك حديث عن عدد من الشهداء اي
في مناطق اخرى لا يتم او لا يستطيع تستطيع
الطواقم الاسعاف الوصول الى هؤلاء الشهداء
وانتشار هؤلاء الشهداء ونقلهم الى
مستشفيات محافظه خانيونس في ظل الحصار الي
اليات الاحتلال على المناطق الغربيه من
المحافظه ننوه بان هناك الطريق الشمالي
الغربي من ناحيه منطقه الصناعه التابعه
للوكاله طريق مفتوح ويستطيع المواطنون
التحرك من هذا الطريق واتجاه المنطقه
الغربيه والاجزاء الشرقيه من معسكر وحي في
في خانيونس لكن في ظل خطوره صعبه مع
استمرار النار مع استمرار القصف المدفعي
في كافه المحاور كافه المناطق في محافظه
خانس ال الدخان ما زالت تتصاعد حتى هذه
اللحظه في اكثر من منطقه القصف المدفعي
مستمر العمليه الحاليه بالنسبه للايات
احتلال تتركز في الاجزاء الغربيه من
المحافظه
في محيط جامعه الاقصى الى الشرق من هذه
الجامعه حيث تتواجد هذه الاليات وتقوم
باعمال تجريف وتدمير في تلك المنطقه تتج
باتجاه احد المواقع العسكريه على ما يبدو
التابع للمقاومه الفلسطينيه تحت غطاء ناري
كثيف وعنيف سواء من اطلاق قذائف او من قبل
اطلاق النار باتجاه اهداف والمواطنين حركه
المواطنين داخل جامعه الاقصى محدوده من
ولكن هناك بوابتين للجامعه هناك بوابه
شماليه وبوابه جنوبيه حركه المواطنين
اتجاه البوابه الشماليه تنطوي عليها يعني
خطوره بالغه فيتجه المواطنون باتجاه
البوابه الجنوبيه حتى يتسنى لهم سلوك
ممرات امنه باتجاه الشارع الغربي في
محافظه خونس ومن ثم التحرك من تلك المنطقه
الى مناطق اكثر امنا سواء في مدينه رفح او
حتى في الاجزاء الغربيه من مدينه خونس
القصف المدفعي مستمر ك تستمعون في خلفيه
الصوت هذا قصف مدفعي في اجزاء الجنوبيه في
محافظه خان يونس كل الاجزاء سواء الشرقيه
او الغربيه من المحافظه هناك يعني السن
الدخان تصعد من اكثر من مكان نتيجه هذه
الغارات وكذلك القصف المدفع العنيف